pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
et
[Musique]
oui ceci est une histoire vraie des
centaines de documents et de témoignages
écrits la teste et l'eau s'est efforcé
de présenter les événements et les
personnages sans romanesque ni
complaisance elle a pour cadre le
gévaudan notre actuel lozère alors
diocèses de la province de languedoc en
ce milieu du xviiie siècle
d'immenses forêts couvraient dans le
coffre cette terre rude et tourmenté
encastrée dans l'auvergne entre les
hauts plateaux de l'aubrac et les gorges
profondes de l'allier les temps sont
difficiles permanente la disette proches
ont encore le souvenir des guerres de
religion et des dragonnades et voici que
s'achève l'été 1764
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
bref à y arrivera ça fait un moment que
je regarde descendre entre opposants
berger oms en briques où on dirait mes
moutons cet office qui légaré qu'est ce
qui là encore fils juste drôle
il a peut-être eu des ennuis je vais y
voir sa compagne jean pierre rentre à la
ferme les moutons reviennent
[Applaudissements]
beauvais
david
eux savaient
[Musique]
à
ah ah
[Musique]
à
on n'avait jamais rien vu d'aussi
horrible monsieur le curé à fig et
orange et jusqu'à l'os plein nez tu
devais toujours plus rien el chato la
halle qui voyait ça j'aurais voulu la
semaine pour l'empêcher de regarder
comment satie pu arriver le petit aura
fait une chute dans le ravin et ce sera
tué sur les rochers ça n'explique pas le
reste pas de bêtes charnière capable
d'une telle horreur en plein jour
impensable cette saison ils s'approchent
petit village
enfin
enfin peut-être
ou alors un char à j-1 matin voulu
sauvage elle rendait encore là car on a
entendu crier
on est allé chercher de l'aide j'en
attends t'es tu as des bus qui a sept ou
huit impossible à retrouver la du fil en
trois temps mais alors comme l'éclair on
a fait le guet elle n'est pas revenue au
cadavre
falloir organiser une grande battue et
au plus vite
attention monsieur le curé une
abomination pareil ce serait comme
vengeance alors agent ma fille ok 2,6
courage on sait que vous êtes avides et
dans la joie auprès du seigneur et vous
retrouverez un jour pour un bon avec
armelle
[Musique]
c'est pas possible j'ai prévu
elle est rien
qu'est-ce que vous avez juste un
cauchemar a expliqué vous qu'est ce que
tu as vu
indique dit lui ça vous soulagera
longueurs des deux yeux qui brillaient
dans le noir de la fenêtre
et puis la pâte comme si une bête
s'appuyait sur le rebord pour se hisser
quelques chats et j'ai vu une patte
grosse comme ça comme ça vient nours
avec des griffes qui s'accrochent au mur
je deviens foule très trop enduré
aujourd'hui châteauneuf et les us vont
poser et vous aussi ma vie rien qu'un
moment c'est trop d'émotions petit
ce carré on peut les voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a fait peur de dieu qu'est ce que
tu fais là je vais chercher de lure à
cette heure ci pittman heureuse et
monsieur le curé je vais tous les soirs
s'est pas défendu
allez donne moi ton ce je vais être
accompagnés c'est marrant qui montre la
fontaine messi s'est défendue je lui
dirai mais non mais non tu diras rien du
tout ne s'est pas défendu aller marche
il faut que je passe d'un jardin ici
c'est fermé oui allez avance avance à
[Applaudissements]
notre vie si nous sommes si le clip
bonsoir d'anvers est ferme mais pas des
modèles ou à l'aide au secours
[Applaudissements]
une chaufferie doit on va dire le
contraire des dragons à cheval sachs
passe pas inaperçu mais blahnik qu'est
ce qu'ils sont venus faire va chercher
leurs officiers nous voulons lui parler
monsieur le consul penser à l'heure ces
messieurs sont encore dans leur chambre
ils ont eu la chance de voir leurs mines
faudra peut-être tout cas si c'est pas
pour les réveiller à dire à leurs chefs
que le consul du malzieu veut lui parler
tout de suite
allez va bien monsieur jeu steve pour
autant de bouées je suis le subdéléguée
vous êtes là aussi oui monsieur
il faut que je vous parle je suis
l'interprète des sentiments de tous
chacun est indienne mettez vous à notre
place les deux malheurs de ces derniers
jours je pense que vous êtes au courant
bien sûr et maintenant les dragons et
convient-il faire que nous volent t-il
nous voulons savoir c'est que je ne leur
en a pris calmez vous je suis arrivé
cette nuit demandé j'allais vous
demander monsieur le consul de réunir
les notables du pays
j'en ferais autant dans les villages
voisins parler maintenant pourquoi
perdre du temps oui pourquoi tant de
mystère dans mes intentions d'art
offertes il dans mes habitudes je
pensais que des habitants du malzieu me
connaissait mieux garer a perdu sa
petite fille l'autre me monsieur de
subdéléguer elle avait 9 ans sa petite
madeleine est morte
saignant en moins de cinq minutes comme
parra boucher est à deux pas de la
maison donc jardin on n'a jamais vu ça
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pardonnez moi
je comprends votre peine elle vous
envoie ce elles se passent en effet dans
ce pays
des événements qui nous préoccupe
beaucoup et c'est ce qui nous amène ici
monsieur duhamel et moi monsieur duhamel
et capitaine de dragon au régiment de
clermont prince messieurs lui et ses
hommes vont prendre leurs quartiers ici
conformément à la mission que leur a
confié monsieur en attendant du
languedoc mais je vous en prie messieurs
asseyez vous nous allons vous dire tout
ce que nous savons
ans
vous nous apportez à voir je vous laisse
la parole messieurs je n'irai pas par
quatre chemins je m'en parlerait aux
soldats j'ai reçu l'ordre de venir en
gévaudan avec ma compagnie pour y
détruire une bête féroce qui sévissait
depuis quelques temps à la cité notre
région
laroche assez jusqu'aux montagnes de la
margeride les difficultés de ce pays lui
ont permis de nous échapper
maintenant elle a chez nous deux enfants
tués en deux jours
le doute n'est guère possible et enfin
pour saigner ma petite conne elle l'a
fait quelle bête
quel genre de bêtes avez vous vu
capitaine non gelée seulement suivi le
passage en passage vous voulez dire de
cadavres en cadavres oui combien
plusieurs nous mêmes pas prononcé un
chiffre et c'est ça que vous appelez
parler un soldat combien
depuis que je suis en campagne l'a tué
17 fois
en combien de temps
un peu moins d'un mois et avant disons
autant
la première agression remonte au début
de l'été elle ne s'attaque qu'aux
enfants
oui surtout aux enfants mais parfois
aussi à des femmes
la première victime a été une paysanne
de 30 ans près de langogne elle a eu la
vie sauve grâce à ses vaches qui ont
chargé la bête à coups de corne
mais si elle n'est pas morte elle a pu
dire à quoi il ressemblait cette baie à
vrai dire elle en a fait une description
à laquelle nous pouvons difficilement
ajouté fois elle a cru voir une sorte de
monstre de la taille d'un jeune taureau
avec une poitrine formidable muses de
lyon type at large et griffu comme celle
d'un ours
mais enfin c'est ce qu'elle a dit donc
vous voyez rien de très sérieux
l'émotion a fait sentir cette femme du
sens commun - je crois je crois qu'il
s'agit d'un loup particulièrement
cruelle à l'eau on avait les loups nous
les connaissons bien les moutons de
leurs affaires même la fin les rampes
assez hardies de s'acharner sur un homme
à moi que soit ton band est encore une
tête qui s'attaque à l'homme pour
l'enseigné le dévorer c'est plus un loup
monsieur duhamel à une autre hypothèse
mais il ya une dizaine d'années lienne
s'était échappé d'une ménagerie pendant
la foire de beaucaire on l'a retrouvé et
tué près de lyon la chose a pu se
reproduire
de toute manière là n'est pas la
question ce qu'il sait de l'abattre au
plus vite
que comptez vous faire mettre tous les
hommes du pays en état d' alerte en quoi
pouvons-nous vous aider n'êtes-vous pas
assez nombreux et bien armés voilà
quatre semaines que cette bête se joue
noir j'ai sans doute manqué de chance
mais j'ai surtout été mal secondes et je
passerai toutes ces forêts toutes ces
montagnes au crible mais pour cela il me
faut les rabatteurs par centaines prêt à
courir au premier rappel du tocsin mais
nous sommes en septembre et les travaux
des champs n'attendent pas à quoi bon se
met aujourd'hui si au printemps vous
n'avez plus de bouches à nourrir
et bien sûr j'interdis que les enfants
il sole garder les troupeaux et qu'il
fera à leur place
vous ferez comme si c'était l'hiver vous
rentrerez les bêtes n'y pensait pas
monsieur le subdéléguée dit leur bien
que ce sont les ordres messieurs les
attend dans des provinces ont donné des
instructions
donc monsieur duhamel et les moyens de
se faire obéir
je me sens
ah si
s'agit-il de notre vie les internes ont
bien nous prendre nos fils pour faire la
guerre aux pros quand sur les routes on
nous laisse crever de faim quand notre
bhl est pourri sur pied et quand une
bête malfaisante venu on ne s'est douté
voir nos enfants c'est encore nous qui
devons lui courir après je connais vos
problèmes
mais réfléchissez pendant que nous
parlons là cette palette cherche sans
doute une nouvelle proie
j'ai vu monsieur duhamel et ses hommes à
l'oeuvre ils ne ménagent pas leur peine
croyable avec votre aide
tout ira très vite
[Musique]
la neige déjà la neige se tenait
on n'a pas eu d'été mais l'hiver est
tout de même venu à son heure
mine de rien qu'on a vieilli peau creed
vous commencez à pester en décembre
qu'en mer on n'a pas fini de vous
entendre
avec la neige on voit mieux la trace des
becs condition que ça s'arrête de tomber
paraît que ce matin il y avait des
marques de pas qu'on pouvait suivre
comme une mode ce n'était pas des bacs
de portes des rigoles de sang tout le
sens d'un petit trouvé avec des
caractères la drôlesse jours à tenir
tête
alors sa mère lui a dit si t'es pas plus
obéissante que la malbaie tu t'emportes
s'était pas plutôt discret jusque dans
les tables quelle a été la chercher la
cad parlez pas de ça chez vous préférez
que je parle de l'hiver et de la neige
on parle de scola dans la tête et qu'est
ce que nous avons tous ici dans les
faits la bête
normalement c'est autre chose on like
olic pour aller de chez soi jusqu'à la
fontaine on crève de peur et j'en
connais qui ont pas des barricades et
leurs portes depuis des semaines qu'ils
doivent se battre avec leurs vaches pour
une poignée de points
essayez donc pas y penser à ces furies
vous avez face à cause d'elle si vous
avez froid à cause d'elle si le tocsin
soit à cause d'elle et si vous homme
vous manque
c'est parce qu'ils courent derrière
cette carte misère comme s'ils pouvaient
l'a rattrapé fois je suis sûr qu'ils ont
les traces comme celle de ce matin par
et qu il n avait jamais il ça fait
bientôt trois mois qu'on nous répète
tous les jours la même chose ne sont
jamais rentrés aussi tard il fait nuit
ils ont dû s'arrêter à l'auberge pour
boire à leur succès leur succès et vous
l'avez bien compris et pas encore née
celle qu'il a des logements elle est
plus rusé que tous les chats plage du
diocèse et l'évêque par dessus le marché
il faut parler ma grand mère c'était un
animal après tout ouais ça vous amuse de
le croire c'était autre chose
enfin ce qu'on pensait
quoi saint-andré qu'ils causent enfants
parce que c'est pas pour rien qu'on
appelle aussi une malade
nous autres on aura bientôt fini n'a de
temps et quand on sera sous terre il va
plus de jeunesse pour nous remplacer
alors elle pourrait s'en donner à coeur
joie dans ces la sarabande dans nos
grands gérault qui reçoit qui lui
appartiennent dans chacune de nos
chemises taisez vous je ne veux pas vous
entendre
même si vous avez raison je crois que ce
soir ce serait folie
il y aura piqué des enfants de macédoine
alors alors vous l'avez vous l'avez tué
les récriminations des paysans sont
arrivés en haut lieu
je peux dire que je suis payé
d'ingratitude donner tout à l'heure au
retour des femmes en trouver le courage
de pousser leurs volets pour nous
insulter
hier deux de mes hommes ont demandé un
peu de pain et d'eau on n'a pas
seulement gagné leur répondre et quand
le trouvons un oeuf ou un fromage à
acheter nous le payons quatre fois son
prix mais quand il doit me reprochez
vous le savez bien
de ne pas avoir encore réussi je
traverse un jour ses villages avec la
bête au travers de ma seule et je serai
fêté comme un héros et j'aurai toujours
eu raison
mais ce résultat il faut que je
l'obtienne seules 11 des villes
j'attends 2000 hommes pour une battue il
n'arrive que la moitié la bête et gorges
mais c'est peut être attendre la lumière
du jour pour le prévenir voyons
capitaine la terreur de ces paysans et
plus normal que votre courage ne suffit
pas de courage quand j'ai besoin cinq
sens avec cette abomination le combat
n'est pas égal dix fois nous aurions dû
l'abattre
quand nous pouvions attirer les
fusillent partait pas dans les grandes
maisons de la charge et sabre au clair
il a fallu qu'un mur se dresse devant
lui le temps de contourner la bête était
déjà loin et aujourd'hui des traces
toute fraîche et encore tienne
et jusqu'au repaire de la bête penser
jusqu'à 1 étant pris une classe que
voulez vous créer un flair là dessus il
avait le nez gelé non nous ne sommes pas
taillés en phase 2 de cette chose
alors monsieur le subdéléguée pensez
vous que nous ayons toujours à faire un
loup vous êtes mieux placé que moi pour
en décider si vous m'affirmer qu'il
s'agit d'un faux je ne crois pas info
mais ce sont encore loin du compte mais
c'est 36 fauve à la fois qu'il faudrait
dire y'a un peu plus mais lyon et cory
dragons chimères la bête de l'apocalypse
si vous préférez je sais ce que vous
pensez la bête du gévaudan a fait une
nouvelle victime et deux capitaines
duhamel est devenu fou mais non notre
évêque lui mais a fait ordonner des
prières de 40 heures sacrement sera
exposé dans toutes les églises comme au
temps des plus grandes calamités
ce qui veut dire que pour lui aussi la
bête du gévaudan n'est pas un animal
ordinaire d'arrêt du g là-dessus
amendement qui sera nous demain dans
tout le diocèse à la messe de minuit
demain
mon dieu c'est déjà noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une bête féroce l'inconnu dans le climat
par étapes comme par miracle par tous
doit se montrent elles laissent des
traces sanglantes de sa cruauté
ils les hommes les plus intrépides sont
saisis de frayeur à la pensée de cet
horrible animal destructeur de nos
espèces prg maire qui avait la douleur
de voir vos enfants égorgés par ce
monstre que dieu armés contre leur vie
l'avez-vous pas lieu de craindre d'avoir
mérité par vaux des règlements que dieu
les frappe l'un fléau si terrible fléau
de dieu voilà que maintenant tout est la
faute
dites moi un peu pour quels grands
péchés nous avons mérité ça monsieur le
curé
c'était quoi les crimes de ma fille et
de châteauneuf pour que le bon dieu se
venge sur notre petit david mais
monseigneur a pas voulu dire ça quand on
est moins bien il a souhaité que chacun
fasse son examen de conscience
donc je frion adieu plus de ressentir et
plus de vertu c'est pas le meilleur
chemin pour regagner sa miséricorde
ouais en tout cas le bon dieu c'est pas
nous qui l'avons bien en colère lévesque
sera bien mieux de regarder dans son
jardin ah non jamais c'est un peu ce que
vous dites mais est bien soutane ou pas
est un beau monsieur de parilly votre
évêque il est venu ici que vous changez
vos habitudes d'un liturgie parisienne
qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire en gévaudan
et voilà le résultat
est-ce que vous allez chercher nous
avions nos salles de cérémonie et nos
églises et le bon dieu les aime et
qu'ils étaient à temps il se reconnaît
plus voilà pourquoi nous a abandonnés
oui oui abandonné à nous mêmes et les
suppôts du diable s'en donnent à coeur
joie
mais qu'est ce que tout ça a à voir avec
la malbaie tu n en fait pas d'innocents
monsieur le curé
cet animal on lèvera pas de l'idée que
les marches pas besoin vous aussi vous
aussi vous colportez toutes ces semblent
être des sornettes et v10 et sorciers ça
n'existe pas peut-être quoi vous n'êtes
pas de labessière la russian la vue sur
la baie sur un village comme les autres
le jeu au prix est encore de loin mais
la nuit et pavon s'y promener ni rentrer
dans certaines maisons de là haut ils
ont là il sort tout le pays et les
mauvais sorts glisse dans la vallée
comme feuilles à l'automne
j'ai voudrait 7 père en fils ils
connaissent tardan vous des bêtes et
gens ceux de la bessière mes grands
mères c'est pas chrétien de parler comme
ça et parler comme l'a fait avec ces
chrétiens
enfin quoi les loups ont pas besoin de
mettre pour attaquer les compos bien sûr
monsieur l'instinct et dédaigné les
routes ont ils manger les enfants des
hommes mois dans leurs habitudes tout ce
que vous voudrez ya quand même des
choses bien étranges châteauneuf a
découvert notre petit david au fond du
ravin
il a d'abord cru qu'il dormait et
pourquoi
parce qu'il avait son chapeau bien calés
sur le visage comme un qui veut dormir
au soleil
on aurait pu passer dix fois à côté sans
s'inquiéter
c'est rouler comme ça ma fille hasard
aussi la petite molinier appuyé sur un
rocher comme si elle voulait regarder le
paysage
il a fallu qu'on fasse tout pour que la
tête par d'un côté une fort de l'autre
mais tout ça ça prouve rien surtout pas
que de braves paysans des paysans comme
vous elle soit pour quelque chose dans
toutes ses horaires où c'est ce qu'on
sait
tenez vous connaissez mes cousines mur à
celle qui habite le coup four elles sont
venues nous voir hier il leur est arrivé
une drôle d'aventuré
c'était en novembre dernier elle
revenait de la foire du pouget par la
route qui longe de bois de favars en
arrivant à la hauteur du bois voilà la
jument qui donne des signes d'inquiétude
du sahara ma cousine décent pour voir ce
qu'elle avait et au même moment un homme
sort des fourrés
il lui dit que le cheval boîte qu'elle
peut pas continuer comme ça qui va les
guider par un raccourci il prend le pied
de la bête comme pour prouver que les
bleus c'est sous le sabot c'est alors
que ma cousine a vu le bras de l'homme
ils étaient tous couverts de poils si
l'on est si serré qu'on aurait dit une
fourrure
ma cousine a pris peur et la relance et
la jument galop et l'homme a disparu en
courant dans les bois quelques minutes
après elle rencontrait un groupe de
chasseurs ils traquer la bête qui
s'étaient réfugiées langoat faveur et
cet homme qui voulait les entraîner là
justement où se trouvait la bête
vous savez que c'était monsieur le curé
antoine chastel le fils de jean chastel
le garde-chasse de labessière vous dites
que des sottises
moi je le connais bien jean chastel le
manga d'élite réponse on se voit pas
souvent mais on est restés bons amis
c'est un honneur chrétiens le père dit
pas bénéfice est un renégat c'est pas
pour rien que ça rase à lui on a tous
une croix sous le pied pour que chacun
de ses pas serait une offense à
jésus-christ vous y était river et même
si c'était vrai
c'est sa faute si les par paresse que
l'on fait prisonnier sur la mer alors
pourquoi ce casting comme un pestiféré
dans les grottes de la tenait hier avec
pour seule compagnie des mâles ans et
demi sauvage sans doute parce que ces
chiens sont plus charitable que vous
la dialyse à dire qui en a l'air vient
jamais seule nous avions la bête
voilà maintenant de nouvelles
malédiction suspicion et la calomnie le
connais ce thème seulement antoine
chastel vos cousines décrit l'homme et
on a tous connu misr quand on vous fera
voir et toucher le cadavre de la bête
vous aurez honte de ce que vous avez
pensé la malle bêtes mortes
alors monsieur le curé en s'y prenant
comme on s'y prend on n'est pas prêt de
l'avoir et vos clubs chanteront la même
chanson à pâques à noël graët tocsin
durant le sanglant divers 1765
le capitaine duhamel organise deux
gigantesques battu le dimanche 7 février
il mobilise les hommes de 78 paroisse du
gévaudan 40 d'auvergne et 20 du rouergue
27 mille paysans tente de réduire la
bête
[Musique]
capitaine la bête est élevé elle file
vers la truyère
on la pousse vers le gain qui tient les
bords de la rivière
les hommes du malzieu il ya deux ou
trois confusion parmi eux le consul et
le tueur et son excellent chasseur
regardez
enfin qu'est ce qu'ils attendent pour
l'attirer non mais je postais sur
l'autre rive c'est un fait restons ici
ne faut pas la folie on dirait qu'elle
passe le guette tout beau comme un singe
comme un homme
il faudra qu il la tire avant qu'elle
atteigne l'autre rive mais ce bond sans
feu
ils sont pétrifiés ma parole elle fait
encore nous échapper
la bête est passé trop loin mon cou a
remporté misère de misère les eaux
pourquoi n'ont ils pas tiré était tout
seul non ce sont les individus sont pas
venus vous entendez monsieur la france
n'entend donner leur vécu
mais ils ont peu plus c'est trop de
misère et de fatigue ou bien des lieux
et des lieux chaque dimanche avec le
ventre creux vous rendez compte que
cette fois il aurait tué la veille et
les autres tous les autres ce qui n'est
pas si froid que sa femme il vous
manqueront dimanche prochain j'exige un
châtiment exemplaire chollima traite
malédiction ou fatalité
la bête une fois de plus avait échappé
aux hommes le 2 avril le consul du
malzieu était emprisonné sur lettres de
cachet les cloches de pâques comme
celles de noël sonnèrent le glas
[Musique]
à
avec le printemps revenu vous
comprendrez monsieur le subdéléguée
qu'il ne me soit pas possible de retenir
les bergers dans les villages
[Musique]
on buvait par la capitale merci je n'ai
pas soif alors je n'ai plus qu'à fermer
boutique
vous êtes mons et le client depuis des
semaines
ils seront accompagnés de soldats dans
la pauvre mesure de mes moyens
et comme la malbaie tu ne s'est jamais
aventuré près des groupes où se
trouvaient des hommes
j'ai essayé d'une nouvelle ruse dont
j'espère qu'elle aura plus de bonheur
que mes autres entreprises la répression
est venue d'obama mais peut toujours
courir tapia pas nous embêter
[Applaudissements]
oui
les goûteurs h
[Applaudissements]
le plus peur c'est parti le jeune berger
qui tint si vaillamment tête à la bête
du gévaudan se nomme chaque portefaix on
dit qu'il est au désespoir d'avoir
laissé s'enfuir le monstre monsieur
dennewald crois que vous allez trouver
en ce jeune paysan 1 et valeureux voulu
apprendre et que sa majesté a décidé de
récompenser son courage en se chargeant
de son éducation aux enfants à
l'officier je le verrais dès mon arrivée
je compte beaucoup plus sûre des
gaillards de cette espèce que sur les
dragons de monsieur duhamel sans doute
monsieur duhamel et ses soldats n'ont
pas répondu à nos espérances mais leur
bonne volonté n'est pas encore au j'en
suis convaincu votre excellence non je
voulais seulement dire que les dragons
sont faits pour la guerre les chasseurs
pour la chasse c'est aussi l'opinion de
sa majesté a
[Applaudissements]
devant les proportions inquiétantes
tu prends cette affaire et là tout de
suite songé à votre belle réputation
vous passez à juste titre pour le
meilleur au pied de france combien de
loups
avez vous déjà accroché à votre tableau
de chasse en un demi siècle plus d'un
millier votre excellence nous comptons
bien que vous ajouterez très vite celui
du gévaudan au nombre de vos victimes
ce sera le fleuron de votre couronne il
est question dans toutes les gazettes
que des méfaits de ce diable d'animal
j'espère ne sera bientôt plus question
que de vos exploits
le roi tient beaucoup parce que tant de
malheurs cesse au plus tôt et puis le
coût et les risques ne sont pas des
seuls à parler de la malbaie comme on
dit au delà des frontières on se gausse
de nous voici ce qu'on pouvait lire il y
a quelques jours dans une feuille de
londres une armée forte de 120 mille
hommes a été défaite par cet animal qui
après avoir avalé tout le train de
l'artillerie s'est trouvée vaincu par
une chatte dont tu avais tu es mort et
les chattes décidément l'esprit n'est
pas le fort des éclaireurs
d'outre-manche leur montrer ce qu'elle
peut faire à lui tout seul un chasseur
normand nous y comptons bien
[Applaudissements]
au nom de notre bon roi louis 15 les
cruautés de la malbaie qui ravagent ce
pays ont ému et touché le coeur
compatissant de sa majesté
elle a ordonné en conséquence d'annoncer
une gratification de 6000 livres enfants
dehors de ceux qui parviendraient à
détruire le ference animal après je dis
des récompenses de 3400 livre déjà
promis une belle ronde à mon jeune ami
si tu avais réussi appelé cet animal tu
serais riche aujourd'hui tu as dû
frapper au défaut de l'épaule ça j'avais
fait plus de dix fois à monsieur mais ça
peut être dur comme de la pierre
je l'appelle écorché de la frapper avec
cette arme est la dame n'est pas en
taille et curieux ça paraît pourtant
avoir de bons bras et c'est sur la table
que je vois un peu
à tous les ascenseurs mais la pétrie
quand lui avant que tu aies pu la
toucher sérieusement allons surprendre
nous sommes bons amis nous l'avons piqué
jean et moi ta vraie jeunes devraient
faire à monsieur delval un portrait de
la belle les autres comme ça monsieur
tous trouvent ça avec une grande
raynouard sur le dos elle a une grosse
touffe cuba sans arrêt elle se tient
tout écrasé au sol
l'arrière un peu relevé mais ses grosses
pattes griffues devant s'enfonce dans la
terre aussi elle a deux grands groupes
qui sortent tous les côtés de la gueule
elle l'a si large que votre tête en
tyrie tiendrait as tu déjà vu des lots
bien sûr monsieur plusieurs fois mort
naturellement vivent aussi tabet ne leur
semble pas au nom de monsieur yalou n'y
a rien d'autre que je connaisse si la
bête écoute mon garçon garde tes
fariboles pour étonner des petits
camarades mais pas de ses comédies là
avec moi tu entends je veux savoir la
vérité c'est la vérité ça prendrait bien
moqué de moi cet enfant vous rapporte ce
qu'il a vu sa déclaration est conforme à
toutes celles qui nous ont été faites
jusqu'ici mais que vous avez gober que
mon oeil je vous en prie monsieur vous
venu ici pour m'insulter je ne pensais
pas que ce fut dans les habitudes de la
cour au la cour c'est quand il convient
d'être sérieux quand il convient de rire
dois je pensais que je vous ai donné
l'occasion de me distraire voyons
messieurs ce qui se passe ici est trop
grave pour que vous créiez suis pourvu
déjà samedi ils sont vrais ça me coûtait
j'espère que monsieur duhamel ten rats
quand même offrir le spectacle de ces
dragons en jupon jeu je souhaite pour ce
pauvre pays monsieur que vous quittiez
sous les acclamations
comme jean parsy vocal ibère mutua même
nom mais rester
restez debout debout les rentrer chez
vous les enfants gérées bravo tard
allait pouvoir pense ganoo régiment dans
lequel tu voudras servir plus tard
puisque le roi tu en donnes de choix
vous êtes sans indulgence pour le
capitaine duhamel monsieur permettez moi
de vous dire que vous n'auriez pas dû
aggraver la peine qu'il a de son échec
il ne mérite pas et convient que nous
soyons tous unis
mais autant que je mens combres de
maladroits que je sais je sais que votre
science de la chasse est sans égal mais
mais vous ne connaissez pas ce pays il
est difficile ce qui s'y passait et
hollande du commun les sens là c'est mon
affaire
mais il vous faudra des aides pour
recueillir les nouvelles pour rassembler
les rabatteurs les soldats de monsieur
duhamel ont l'habitude de ce que le
subdéléguée le roi m'a confié une
mission et vous comprendrez que je
venais amaguiz voudrait bien aussi faire
savoir que j'entends ne pas être gêné
sur le terrain par d'autres fusils il
n'y a qu'un chasseur ici monsieur c'est
moi
[Applaudissements]
printemps 1765 désormais la poursuite de
la bête du gévaudan n'est plus la sphère
que d'un seul homme les hobereaux du
pays et 20 à cesson irrite
mais les paysans eux sont plus
satisfaits c'en est fini des corvées la
bête cependant poursuit ses ravages
[Applaudissements]
patient précis organiser le vieil homme
mais toute sa longue expérience au
service de ce qui sera ils l'imaginent
bien sa dernière grande aventure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en ce jour de l'ascension nous privons
tout particulièrement mais vrai pour
ceux qui sont morts depuis park victimes
de la bête
françois fontes sûrs d'eux c'est l'arrêt
rappelé à dieu le 29 mars
pierre bergounioux de fontan rappelé à
dieu le 2 avril à moto ville de
saint-amand le 4 avril
joseph downey jr d'argent le 5 avril
marche a lieu de chaunac le 16 avril
clos remémore d'un pauliac
le 18 avril jacques boutault de kuffour
le 23 marie-jeanne imbert de ventre et
jaune le 2 mai fu ni les plus cons de
grève le 3 mai et nous prions aussi pour
la guérison du sud
d'échapper à la mairie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est c'est moi monsieur
geoffrey appartenait pas monsieur dans
la portable sachent quoi s'accrocher
d'une valve c'est bien je vous suis l
heure était passé minuit ont préparé mon
cheval fait vite
à
je suis super league au maintien
monsieur chat la sciotte jeu possible
oui oui avant speedy nous en aurons fini
avec la bête du gévaudan et asseyez vous
on sait pas très confortable vous savez
voilà quinze jours que je n'ai dormi
sous un toit à la diarrhée zombies ce
que valait pas l'idée d'un tel pays oui
jamais vu d'aussi sauvage et n'a pendant
quelques heures
l'aventuré sera terminée se joue ce pas
y croire comment avez vous réussi c'est
un animal horizons ces tunnels ou un peu
partout en europe et même jusque dans le
beau monde
celui là c'est une autre histoire une
astuce diabolique les pièges les ennemis
tous vous ne verrez jamais touché un
cadavre empoisonné ou emprunter deux
fois le même sentier inutile de le
suivre à la trace et à loder il s'est
brouillé sa piste mieux canadien
d'amérique et les meilleurs limiers ont
perdu l'odorat et pourtant vous l'avez
enfin trouvée contrainte l animal
monsieur pour se servir de sa tête
c'est souligner les lieux pour et
épauler les derniers crimes il fallait
bien que la bête viennent de son repaire
pour descendre commettre ses forfaits
or ce repère le tout est propre au
centre du faisceau dans une région
difficile d'accès
quelque part entre le mont chauvet et le
mont grands alors je me suis posté là
haut j'ai attendu pendant quinze chose
rare rien m'avait sans doute flairé
meyer et les revenus elle est passée si
près qu'elle a pu être tiré
n'avez vous blesser le chemin est
jalonnée de son sang le brouillard et la
nuit ou lorient achevée maintenant les
piqueurs et mais xiam on l'a levé et l'a
poussé vers cette barrière rocheuse que
vous voyez ici c'est là que nous avons
rendez-vous rémois soleil est déjà haut
les amateurs seront sûrement
[Musique]
elle a passé une partie de la nuit ici
car je te repartir tout sens qu'elle a
perdue ne peut pas aller bien vite en
moins de mystère
[Applaudissements]
côté les chiens ils l'ont senti à les
renier ce pistolet nous sommes près du
but
[Musique]
mais bon
incapable
oui la série
why
la marde tu parlais la peine qu'il
vienne
je ne sais pas je n'ai rien vu pas mal
nous a dupés encore une fois et voilà
[Musique]
et bien voilà s'était échappé par là
chez total elle n'a pas pu sauter le
cette cabane à trancher et trouver une
autre explication mais au moins 30 pieds
d'abord à l'autre à nous ne peut pas
faire à paris bon aure loi ordinaire
peut-être et celui là il a autant
d'intelligence que de force
on dirait que vous en parlez avec
admiration pourquoi pas il faut bien
s'incliner quelquefois ils avaient
raison ce petit portefeuille
vous vous souvenez ce n'est pas un lot
ce n'est aucun animal que je connaisse
c'est la bête
non monsieur le délégué approchait que
les poussines ont fait une place à
monsieur lafon volet vous boire du vin
la news je voudrais surtout vous parlez
hsa racontez-nous des histoires mais
qu'elle soit amusante 1 nous avons envie
drilles apparaître les aime je vous
parlais l'a sérieusement jusque là pour
non plus ne connaît pas l'histoire
beaucoup
alors qu'est ce que c'est vous avez déjà
rencontré châteauneuf portait son fils a
été la première victime de la bête
la première quelle sera la dernière
sellal mahler quelque chose qui commence
mal il ne pas fini châteauneuf a réussi
à faire parler bouki qui ou d'hommes que
nous avons trouvé dans cette cabane du
mont chauvet c'est fabuleux
les rien pu obtenir de lui et moi il
avait sans doute peur de moi
quand vous monsieur mettre à mal bête
lui avait-il promis le silence il avait
peut-être peur qu'elle écoute derrière
la porte
il ne faut pas plaisanter monsieur qui
peut savoir ce que la bête en temps et
ce qu'elle comprend pour qu'ils pensent
que la bête s'est prise d'amitié pour
lui depuis une certaine nuit où ils sont
battus ensemble
battu à mort chacun pour sa vie comme
deux enfants pour le plaisir
enfin c'est ce qu'il croit la bête
revient souvent lui rendre visite
il paraît qu'il lutte jusqu'à tomber de
fatigue alors elle fait la pose à côté
de lui et s'en va sans plus lui faire de
mal
je vous le dis comme il me l'a dit
pourquoi pas
étrange l'eau n'est ce pas monsieur
lafon il y a derrière les divagations de
bookeen une vérité qui nous semble utile
monsieur duval
voilà près de trois semaines que vous
aviez d'abandonner la chasse et je
partageais à votre découragement mais
nous vous apportons la preuve que vous
ne vous étiez pas trompé la bête passe
bien par cette faille entre le mont
chauvet et le mont grand pour gagner son
père et elle continue dit pas c'est vous
qui la revue espaces à temps mais il est
certain qu'à lui ai rendu visite depuis
votre dernière chasse alors monsieur
monsieur je vous en conjure montella les
reprenez les a vus vous vous êtes donné
trop de peine pour ne pas mériter de
triompher mon très cher ami
demain en lisant votre courrier vous
regretterez de m'avoir parlé comme vous
venez de le faire et pourquoi demain
vous apprendrez que monsieur dennewald
n'est plus chargé de vous débarrasser de
la malbaie tu demain vous apprendrez que
je ne suis plus rien car je suis en
disgrâce
c'est pas possible c'est moi le dernier
au nord de le croire ainsi en a décidé
le roi
vous aviez réussi à me reprocher j'ai
commis le crime de déplaire la petite
noblesse amérique prétentieuse de ce
pays qui ne m'ont pas pardonné d'avoir
voulu être seul à mener cette aventure
désespéré me suivre comme mon ombre
profité de la première occasion pour me
voler la victoire
la récompense en même temps voilà
monsieur le subdéléguée comment a
compris l'intérêt de notre diocèse mais
il faut retenir monsieur duval qui a
toute notre confiance sinon qu'on ne
plus jamais sur nous alors monsieur
demain vous aurez pour me succéder le
plus prestigieux des chasseurs de sa
majesté et parez vous accueillir
monsieur temps toile de beaux terne
premier portal cumulus du roi talent et
vous allez entendre de belles fanfare je
voudrais bien être à votre place vu vos
à sa santé si toutefois trinquer avec
moi ne vous semble pas compromettant non
monsieur
vous me voyez confondues que vous êtes
naïf votre gens de province aux nantis
se savait bien qu'il nous faudra gagner
la partie tout de suite avant qu'on me
décerne à la cour
votre bête du gévaudan le savez aussi en
arrivant j'ai compris et maintenant
j'aimerais que j'ai tout perdu
honneur à leur réputation
c'est encore vous que je plains ne me
reste rien il vous reste la bête
[Musique]
le 7 août 1765 d'antoine devaux terne le
lieutenant général des chasses de sa
majesté arrivaient sur place
il emmenait avec lui les meilleurs garde
chasse des capitaineries de saint
germain et de versailles et l'élite des
meutes royal transportés dans des cages
d'osier capitaux ni les poursuites et
les bas dû recommencer le 16 août leurs
recherches les portait du côté de la
bessière sainte marie
[Musique]
et vous vous coupez par la marche est
toujours pas l'air solide
on ne peut pas arriver mais non juste un
peu de boue à esi à des pets nous
confiance nous y passons tous les jours
c'est dans vous avez de belles bottes
tout neuf
vous risquez rien
[Applaudissements]
les jantes et nous l'avons dieuze ya un
[ __ ] cv tech de choses
pardi on vous en sortir au plus tôt on
va tondre à crapule ou de rémédiation
nous trouverons eux
si vous tenez à nous revoir bundle un
vestiaire
vous demanderez les chastel ils ont
volontairement envoyé d'abord trois
quarts de chasse de sa majesté bouquet
du pays vous savez mieux que moi les
dangers que représentent ces marécages
non monsieur le curé je ne peux rien
pour vos chasses terre je regrette ils
demeureront temps présent du moins aussi
longtemps que je resterai en gévaudan
je suis navré que votre miséricorde vous
a poussé à qu'attend de chemin pour
d'aussi mauvais sujets au monsieur
ne jugez pas trop sévèrement les gens
d'ici dans une misère de souffrance et
d'horaires acculé leur oncle bloque
toute mesure et toutes raisons ne sommes
nous pas là justement pour leur rendre
la paire je crois qu'ils ont aussi perdu
confiance
comprenez les il ya eu une culture mr
muscle d'une valve vous maintenant
rassuré les monsieur le curé quels que
soient les mérites de ceux qui vont
précéder il convient de faire la
différence en ma personne c'est le roi
qui vient à votre aide
de sorte qu'en s'en prenant à des hommes
au chastel peut-être sans s'en douter
on fait insulte au roi est bien leurs
amis
le sud est réglé certes certes mais je
ne voudrais pas les réactions des gens
d'ici que si injuste soit talent puisse
entraver votre action mais je tiens
particulièrement à ce que la nouvelle de
l'emprisonnement des chastel souhaité
bruit terre est déjà connu et comme
monter jusque dans les foyers les plus
reculées sont ils dans tellement estimé
c'est selon
observez serait plus juste et pour
certains il existe une relation obscur
entre la bête est en soi neuchâtel le
fils viable et laquelle comment
expliquer ça aux citadins écrit eric
vous êtes il existe encore dans les
montagnes des légendes un des légendes
qui ont la vie dure et moi j'irais pas
jusqu'a dire que tu monique rault moga
rhône
mais pour ce qui est des meneurs de
loups seule chose vous voulez parler de
ces hommes qui selon la fable aurait le
pouvoir de commander les bêtes sauvages
de leur désigner des victimes tout comme
de leur apprendre qui il convient
d'épargné sont des contes à dormir
debout avait su nous étions bien éveillé
quand les lieux nous les raconter et
puis andres bien les chiens
voyez-vous monsieur en arrêtant les
chastel vous avez au volontairement
confirmés dans leurs idées ceux qui
partagent de tels soupçons et les autres
les autres pensent que des hommes comme
chastel et son fils connaissent chaque
pouce carré de cette paire mieux que
personne et qu'il suffirait de les armer
pour
abu-jamal bête armée de paysans mais
vous n'y songez pas je sais trop bien qu
il ne saurait en être question est
aujourd'hui moins que jamais ce pays
n'est plus très sûr
c'est aussi pourquoi il faut le manier
prudemment
monsieur le subdéléguée la france
entière a cessé d'être sûr mais pour ce
qui est du gévaudan je ne suis pas trop
inquiète les moyens dont je dispose me
permettront de vous débarrasser de ce
loup sanguinaire avant que vos paysans
de réagir monsieur vous entendu et comme
on peut croyez vous que ce soit une
grosse affaire pour nous que d'abattre à
nous de plus utile du gévaudan oui mais
s'agit-il bien alou et de quoi d'autre
sinon monsieur lafon j'ai toujours tenté
de garder la tête froide mais j'étais là
quand la bête vous a échappé en un bond
de 30 pieds elle était blessée et la
décade eu beaucoup de sens et pourtant
moins de deux heures plus tard elle est
encore jeune femme a dit lieu de l'a9
vous ne pensez pas monsieur le
subdéléguée mais je crains que vous
n'ayez prêté trop de deux fois aux
exagérations de mots malheureux
prédécesseur le nook il traquait du
s'esquiver tout autrement que vous le
pensez si l'animal carnassier tue est
ailleurs c'est que monsieur d'une valve
était sur une fausse piste
voilà tout ou qu'il existe plusieurs
bête du gévaudan et qu'elle est venue
chercher là il ya dans ces forêts un
loup qui a un prix goût à la chair
humaine et qui puise dans cette
nourriture une force inconnue de ses
congénères
c'est toute l'explication de ce grand
mystère et sans courir les imaginations
elle n'est rompue bien loin
le 15 septembre après quatre semaines de
chasse infructueuses d'antoine devaux
terne écrivait à sa femme que reste-t-il
de sa belle assurance
vous savez ma très chère femme que je
suis ici par la confiance que m'ont
témoigné sa majesté et monsieur de saint
florentin cette confiance me rend me
faisais un impérieux devoir je suis bien
prêt de penser que je les trahisse ne
voyons pas pourquoi après tant et tant
d'efforts vains les temps à venir
pourraient être plus favorables que les
jours passaient et les gorges de
l'aveyron
quelle forme et celui du château
messieurs on a trouvé l'enfant juste
devant la grand'porte il faut prendre la
piste
regardez la nuit monsieur organes abouti
et là tu m'a plu c'est votre faute vous
entendez c'est votre faute
c'est notre présence qui n'attire une
jamais demandé par ici nous prouve que
c'est comme si vous l'aviez assassinat
mais calmez vous mon ami je comprends ce
que vous ressentez tout ce que je puis
faire pour vous je le ferai allez-vous
gens n'y a jamais eu autant de malheurs
que depuis que vous êtes là alors qu'est
ce que vous dites est laissée aux
m'accabler mais je ne vous en veux pas
je trop de peine pour vous et les autres
je ne vais pas vous reproche vous savez
bien que je fait l'impossible se trouve
un pauvre petit bonnet l'avoir on et
voir ce qu'il en a fait elle était si
belle vous savez
pourquoi les gens font tant de misère
pourquoi rentrez chez vous on va vous
raccompagner je viendrai vous voir
demander tout ce dont vous aurez besoin
je suis soyez bons et de l'heure de me
rendre ma fille je ne veux pas que le
serbe da par sa mère en deviendra un
pôle je ne veux pas qu'on le remplissent
le corps de boisement ma pauvre fille
ensuite il rendait là moi monsieur pour
vous prouver la ramener chez vous mais
monsieur et à quoi bon ces cruautés qui
deviennent gratuites
aidez le à transporter sa fille
on
pellissier je sais bien que cet homme va
s'ouvrir plus que moi et pourtant il est
dit des choses inadmissibles la douleur
ligue 1 comment on ne penserait t-il pas
que la bête est venu dévorer sa fille
jusque sous mes fenêtres comme pour me
définir
on dira tout aussi bien versailles quand
on sera ce nouveau elle attend deux
jours que nous lui court après s'en
apercevoir plus que son ombre
et elle vient ici pour me narguer c'est
pas possible il faut en finir par
n'importe quel moyen
on ne se moque pas ainsi des chasseurs
du roi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
mais
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais surtout c'est bien le 22 septembre
1765 éclatait la nouvelle tant attendue
la veille même au cours d'une expédition
est clair dans les bois de l'abbaye
royale des chazes antoine devaux terne
avait tué la bête du gévaudan
[Musique]
pour moi sa majesté et d'une joie
inexprimable et moi même je ne sais
comment vous dire toute ma satisfaction
il faut que je vous embrasse le graphe
monsieur c'est trop de bonté j'ai mis
tant de lenteur à remplir la mission que
vous m'aviez confié nous avons été tenus
au courant des toutes les difficultés
que vous avez dû surmonter et la peine
qu'elle vous en donner et l'intendant
nous pardonner que des éloges pour votre
courage et votre ténacité
nous n'étions pas surpris mais nous
avions plaisir à lire
le roi m'a chargé de vous conduire à lui
dès votre arrivée
je ne vous dis rien de l'accueil que les
pauvres on prépare je sais que vous lui
réservez le récit votre exploit mais je
pas pitié ne fait pas trop souffrir ma
curiosité
alors cette bête du gévaudan kenneth ce
que sa majesté et vous même avez
toujours pensé un loup tout bonnement
mais de quelle taille
vous en jugerez j'ai fait dépouiller la
bête est monté la pause sur une forme de
bois ou proportion exacte vous en aurez
assez l'image très fidèle le regard
excepté qui avait avec la quasi
insoutenable mais vous pourrez observer
la mâchoire vous
nombreux et 40 dans alors que les loups
ont accoutumé d'un mois 26 voix la
terrible trophée il ne va pas manquer de
faire s'évanouir maintes personnes du
beau sexe
de quelle couleur est le pelage de
semences d'aghribs très profond tant pis
j'espère que la cour il parlera
auraient-elles en horreur les fourrures
de ce ton jeu vous n'y êtes pas elle
vient de lancer la mode des étoffes d'un
certain art ou qu'elle a baptisé couleur
de la berd
je lui présenterai mille excuses il est
temps de partir
le roi est impatient pour tous nous
permettions me faire languir
vous savez que je confesseur de sa
majesté a été particulièrement sensible
au fait que c'était un coup de fusil est
eu pour cadre les bois de l'abbaye
royale mais il m'a surpris en prétendant
que les charges ne se trouvait pas en
gévaudan
ah mais c'est la raison monsieur
pardonnez-moi mais le couvent des chazes
est situé en auvergne vous pouvez
enlever la main vous avez du beau temps
pour le voyage tant mieux la route ne
paraîtraient moins longue
bref des mois avec la voiture sera prête
comme c'est gentil d'être venus durant
bras je suis las et fatigué comme jamais
au cours de ces terribles 18 mois que
nous venons de passer
nous sommes venus vous demander de
rester encore quelques jours elle pas ça
serait bien volontiers mais on me
réclame
vous n'imaginez pas combien de dossiers
se sont accumulées sur mon bureau
non je sentais rester
d'ailleurs mes séjours allemande était
cible est là bas aussi que je ne
m'occupais que dans cette bête pour dit
maintenant que nous en voici des livres
et je vais retrouver des tâches plus
banal
dieu merci et si la bête n'était pas
morte
oh non non non non je vous en prie
monsieur le consul ne revenons pas là
dessus on attend couru après cette date
seront sans effets d'image tellement
singulière qu'il est difficile de se
soumettre à l'idée qu'il ne s'agissait
que d'un loup si remarquable soit-il le
loup tué par d'antoine ariane très
remarquée l'animal un carnassier de près
de 150 livres que vous faut-il de plus
son point explique si sa vitesse et son
agilité et nous contraignent les
chirurgiens apothicaires ont parlé dans
leur rapport d'une disposition du
squelette tout à fait particulier mais
ce rapport nous l'avons lu comme vous
monsieur le délégué et quand ils
trouvaient dans l'estomac du loup de
monsieur d'antoine les chirurgiens rien
que des bouts d'os de mouton et la bête
ne s'est jamais attaqué aux moutons
c'est là toute la différence est là
debout que pour la chaire humaine
il est donc difficile de se débarrasser
de ce que la terreur 2 a fait l'autre à
imaginer on aurait vu promener le cada
par tout le pays
nous aurions pu ainsi toucher du doigt
la fin de nos malheurs du prix mais
voilà on s'est bien gardé de nous le
montrera comprenait pas ce qu une
poterne il était un passeur de
satisfaire la curiosité du roi mais il
aura au moins fallu qu'elle souhaitait
de par chez nous cette bête et non pas
au diable vauvert et précisément dans
les jardins d'une abbaye royale en
auvergne l'hôtel l'allier on n'avait
jamais entendu dire qu'elle avait
traversé l'allier on n'avait jamais
entendu dire qu'elle ferait si loin oui
et puis qu'est-ce qui a bien pu donner
l'idée à d'antoine de partir chasser sur
les terres des chahuts avait signalé des
ravages de ce côté sûr et on s'est
empressé d'élaguer les sentiers on nous
l'affirmait quoi faire fuir les loups à
cent lieues à la ronde et la bête était
quand même au rendez vous ça ne vous
paraît pas incroyable
et si je n'ai aucune raison de mettre en
doute la parole de monsieur leubou terre
mais nous si on ne nous enlèvera pas de
l'idée qu'il s'agit d'un coup monté pour
l'honneur du roi
ça c'est là une opinion bien audacieuse
qu'elle consultait vous n'avez même pas
un commencement
mais écoutez moi monsieur lafon le 18 au
soir
de mystérieux colis arrive au château du
besset où loge monsieur d'antoine le
nouveau chien paraît-il comme s'il n'y
en avait pas assez des meilleurs le
lendemain les colis repartent pour les
chats ce monsieur qui promenait ses
dignes et dans les paniers fort et
n'hésite pas tout à coup à crever les
nouveaux venus en dalle béton que ce
soit les chiens le surlendemain
monsieur d'antoine part à son tour et 24
heures après la bête tombe sous sékou a
pas pas soudain donc la chance avait
tourné elle a été si longtemps favorable
à la bête
admettons mais le soir même monsieur
d'antoine était de retour au château où
se trouvait déjà réuni quelques témoins
qui reconnurent la bête du gévaudan sans
coup férir et signèrent tout ce qu'ont
voulu mais du bus et aux phases
il y avait un beau lieu et des plus
mauvaises mains le cheval de monsieur
antoine devait avoir des ailes mais
admettons encore mais le lendemain le 22
le loup tué aux charges étaient
présentés à l'intendant de clermont
ferrand et ça monsieur le subdéléguée
vous le savez aussi bien que nous on ne
peut pas en un jour aller du bus et à
clermont ferrand ce n'est pas possible
nous n'avons peut-être pas de preuve
mais nous avons du bon sens nous la
vérité c'est que dans les colis arrivé
le 18
y'avait pas des chiens et neil aux trois
lots captifs dont l'ats a été poussé
comme un cerf devant le tromblon du
lieutenant des chasses de sa majesté en
dit que le second attendait au château
d'être reconnu par quelques enfants
bousculer effrayé et que le troisième
était déjà en route pour versailles en
passant par clermont ferrand là je sais
je sais je sais que voulant défendre et
pas le gévaudan ne peut plus vivre sans
sa bête
et si je me disais que j'ai reçu une
lettre de monsieur duval et que beaucoup
pensent de même avec monsieur donne mal
monsieur des prélats quelques raisons de
pouvoir se réjouir de ce succès
enfin merci à tous
faites devant le cas du groupe incliné
lui et nous c'est que depuis la chasse
du 21 septembre
depuis l'achat temps monsieur debout
terne la planète n'a plus fait victime
est alors et j'ai déjà arrivé de se
tenir quelques gens tranquilles ya
quelques jours oui mais là ça fait bien
deux semaines notre voiture et c'est
parfait merci au revoir monsieur est
bien au revoir monsieur de ce délégué
puisqu'il ne peut en être autrement
enfin en admettant en admettant contre
toute vraisemblance que la bête
réapparaissent en quoi puis-je vous êtes
au tir mais vous seriez là pour dire en
haut lieu j'ai vu de mes propres yeux
que la malle bête n'est pas morte
nous on pourra toujours le jurer sur ce
que nous avons de plus sacré qui le
croira
non je crois je crois très sincèrement
que vous trompez
comme nous le voudrions
[Musique]
octobre novembre
les jours et les semaines passent
paisible justifiant tous les espoirs
redonnant confiance aux pays à la fin de
l'automne le gévaudan avait recommencé à
vue
[Musique]
elle m'aurait suffi d'un bon coup de
hache pour la tuer ce soir là il aurait
été le dernier et gorgés notre pauvre
david hay adams à tournai
on n'est pas resté près d'une minute
derrière reçu était suffisant pour que
la bête les gorges et disparaissent pas
la dette et qui d'autre c'est pas
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi vaudrait
mieux que la bête est mince ma fille
n'en doutez bien mais il est une autre
victime non mais une petite agnès
mourgues du village de l'ours hier
pendant rêver il a le tour mais on ne
puis du changement de pilote
takan ses camarades il a réussi à le lui
reprendre
elle l'aura la prochaine occasion oui
mais voilà revenus revenus n est jamais
repartie bien caché la carte jusqu'à
temps qu'il fallait pour de sucer
d'espoir elle va se rattraper un canal
tu penses tu as beau chasseurs du roi
9400 livres pour avoir tué un loup bonne
affaire dont on dit qu'ils ont gagné
plus de 200 milles en montrant la baisse
à paris ailleurs enfin sa bête
non la bête du gévaudan faut bien se
mettre ça dans la tête c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont donc décidé nos princes on
pourra bien seigner crever créiez lui
personne ne parlera de nous est morte
elle est morte
et quand le roi sera elle ferait bien
commencé les charleroi je sais même pas
c'est comme il l'a voulu
s'il ya une machination non je peux pas
croire que le roi en soit complice
complice ou du le pen peut plus que ce
taire la vérité n'était pas tel que vous
imaginez monsieur lafon pensais qu'il y
avait sans doute plusieurs bêtes féroces
qui aient vent et le monde possible
monsieur le curé mais il ne l'admettront
pas non plus puisqu'on vous dit qu'il
l'ont tué la bête du gévaudan henric a
reçu une lettre de danival lui disant
que l'emploi n'avait reçu la permission
d'ajouter l'image de la bête blason de
sa famille grand bien lui fasse
vous en déplaise monsieur le curé il
avait fait qu'une seule chose de bien à
votre beau chasseurs mettre les chastel
en prison oui tellement l'air voilà
libres maintenant
alors maintenant qu'est ce que vous
allez faire on va essayer de se défendre
seul le faut bien
mais après tout ce sera pas plus mal
ce soir là je pouvais écrire ce ne fut
pas plus mal mais je ne suis pas mieux
livrés à eux mêmes les paysans sarre
maire comme ils le furent quelques
gentilshommes prirent la tête des
chasses et organiser les battues
[Musique]
la même sanglante partie de cache-cache
recommence à tout un long hiver tout en
gaieté et un hiver encore
[Musique]
à
pas
[Musique]
le 16 mai 10 767 une enfant de 12 ans
marie d'anti mouret ce n'était qu'une
victime de plus de la malle bête mais
elle était de la baie sears sainte marie
[Musique]
on m'a dit que tu étais venu
pour partie son du tour je me demandais
[Musique]
pas si souvent ambitieux ont été remises
aux échasses tout on dit tellement de
choses sur nous
j'en entend tellement d'autres
confessions
elle était gentille la drôlesse
mad men est souvent joué à la maison
elle sauté par dessus le mur du jardin
tu l'as lu baïkal alors je ne peux pas
on s'y habitue par les boîtes à dieu
sait si j'en ai vu
tu sais combien leur nature on dit près
de 200
genre genre si cette petite pouvait être
la dernière
il faudrait il faudrait bien
oui
tu voulais m'ouvrir pour quelque chose
j'ai franck dudt ses trois balles
[Musique]
sont faites avec les médailles de la
vierge alors
je voudrais que tu te bénisse
tu vois
il suffirait d'une balle une
[Musique]
un mois plus tard le 19 juin 1767 jean
chastel prenait la fuite dans les bois
de la tenait hier ils lisaient les
litanies de la vierge quand il entendit
d'un froissement d'herbe
il leva les yeux par le sentier la bête
venait droit sur lui ont dit qu'il prit
le temps de fermer son livre et de
ranger ses lunettes avant d'épauler et
que la bête là tandis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bed
tu n'en mangera plus
[Musique]
jean chastel avait tué la bête du
gévaudan l'animal fut conduite au petit
trot à paris pour y être présenté au roi
et au grand naturaliste buffon mais la
route est longue et la chaleur torride
ce fut une charogne qui arriva à
versailles louis 15 ordonna qu'on la vit
temps retiré sur le champ
pouvait-il en être autrement ni lui ni
monsieur de buffon ne sur ce qu'était au
juste la bête du gévaudan a plus que ne
le sur la bas les petits bergers
mais ce qu'il sur eux les petits bergers
du gévaudan c'est qu'on ne les mangent
et plus
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]